aurélie moi je t'ai connu à l'époque où
tu donner des recettes de cuisine dans
un journal qui s'appelait annie aime les
sucettes tu t'en souviens
ah oui mais pas fait c'est que je vais
me donner des recettes de cuisine
j'écrivais plus tôt ce parce que pour
moi être important c'était d'articles de
son j'écrivais dans ce ce fanzine
héroïque mais oui oui c'était l'époque
héroïque que c'est l'époque des stinky
toys et elle est en question tout à fait
c'est ldd pour tous qu'est-ce qui fait
jacques mais aujourd'hui
là il vient de produire le
nouvel album de daniel darc il a composé
pas mal de musique de cet album jeunesse
j'écoute et quelques chansons c'est bien
c'est vraiment c'est que ça vraiment
j'aime beaucoup daniel choqué et très
très beau chant très bien enfin bon je
rêve en tant que rockstar démarre là je
crois que ça va démarrer très fort il en
train de préparer la tournée tu vois
toujours on se voit pas souvent mais on
se téléphone très souvent tous les
combien ça fait pour lui ça dépend des
périodes ces derniers jours on s'est
beaucoup appelé et puis on se pare vent
l'enquêteur c'est inquiète pas qu'ils
aient plus d'avant garde qu'on voit les
mêmes de des temps dans toutes les
émissions se dire que tu passes chez
drucker que tu vas chez sabatier que tu
passes brandon 00h15 et pas vraiment non
j'ai l'impression qu'il n'ya plus
d'avant garde tout le monde pas chez
tout le monde
nous on est ravi de t'avoir non je sais
pas tout le monde s'est rangé des
voitures des mères de famille tu fais
des émissions une canne mais c'est bien
pour toi mais c'est pas bizarre quand
même qui est plus des gens comme les
stinky toys à l'école mais bon je ne
sais pas moi pareil cas les techniques
et a salué à l'époque les gens vont
changer c'est pas toi non pas moi je
fais magie
tu vois si on m'avait proposé de refaire
à l'époque je le resterai donc c'est
vrai qu'à changer
c'est peut-être le caire consommation
est-ce que tu centre est capricorne ce
centre et frappe
ouais je crois très côté sérieux
opiniâtre des capricornes âge as tu eu
très très dur très très bien situé quand
je vois quelque chose à savoir pourquoi
la bande s'élaborer est ce que tu es
enfin qu'est ce que ça te fait cette
montée disponible en ce moment puisque
tu t'y attendais ou est ce que tu es
heureusement surprise
moi j'attends ça depuis que j'ai
commencé à faire la musique quand même à
l'époque des stinky taj
j'ai pas tellement les souks espagnol
quand même il y avait des chansons
espagnoles
il y avait chanté soit en anglais sont
espagnols j'ai essayé de
introduire des toits de côté jean
arrangements perd quelque chose comme ça
et puis tout le monde le dit j'aime les
gens peuvent pas comprendre sa voix sa
prévision en tout à l'heure tu vas
chanter bonhomme tout nouveau titre
inutile deux anciens type je suis très
heureux et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu